members of the executive officers
members of the public welcome to this
meeting of the executive Rochford
District council's executive
if I can turn to item one as we open the
meeting
apologies for absence have been received
from councilor Arthur Williams but I
think everyone else is present
if I look to non-members attending
councilor Ian Foster I see in the
audience so uh welcome councilor Foster
minutes of the meeting held on the 7th
of March 2023
members of the minutes agreed as an
accurate record
agreed
thank you
for to receive any Declarations of
Interest
are there any declarations on items this
evening
moving to item five questions on notice
from counselors members there are none
agenda item number six matters referred
to the executive and reports from other
committees uh members there is one
report from overview and scrutiny
committee the review of improvements
within the development management team I
believe I'm turning initially to Yvonne
Dunn to to introduce or is it EU
councilor Ward you can decide between
the two of you
hey London welcome thank you thank you
chair
um yes so the report that's in front of
the committee tonight is a following a
report requested by the overview and
scrutiny committee which met on the 1st
of March 2023 and it was initiated for a
review of improvements within the
development management team and what the
report covered was the review that was
conducted in 2019 a further review in
2021 and then subsequent
implementations of those recommendations
and then also further recommendations
were put forward to the committee as to
what the development management team
envisaged to be carried out to
continuous continuous Improvement there
was seven recommendations on the table
chair
um
and those recommendations were to
arrange a follow-up of the review of the
development Management Service via the
planning advisory service to assist with
the one team review that further options
are explored with the one team
partnership to create additional
capacity across both councils three was
to continue to work on improving the
customer experience through online
improvements and digital technology four
provide a full pre-application service
from April 2023 as a discretionary
service five to provide members with
planning application decisions for their
Awards and six to implement quarterly
performance and monitor and reporting to
members councilor Foster actually
requested a seventh recommendation and
there has been some revised wordings to
that recommendation that I believe
Council award will be speaking to
shortly
and yes so it those recommendations are
put forward to the executive tonight for
for approval so our past Council award
just to confirm
thank you very much indeed Yvonne
um again with the recommendations that
are there the six they are an echo
chamber on 6.4 and item five
um so it would seem as if the other
exclusionary committee had actually read
the report and seen everything in there
which I'm pleased about
um item seven uh there is a there is a
change which I shall read out now
and that changes and I'll read it nice
and slow
that for major development and planning
applications that have generated
substantial public interest
officers should seek Ward counselor
comments on conditions before discharge
if the details vary from the planning
application and so that will be item
seven
on those
thank you councilor Ward
um
are there any comments on the um on the
report in front of you
um
people have done this very kindly read
out the first six recommendations and
you've gone for an amendment for uh item
seven as it's issued in the uh in the
agenda pack tonight do you have a
seconder for uh that amendment I hope so
Council sparing thank you thank you
um and before we go any further it might
be helpful if you actually make a
proposal on your recommendations and
then I'll open it up for uh for
discussion thank you chairman yes I
propose that Amendment at item seven and
do you want me to read it again no I
think I'd be grateful if you would also
propose items one to six I will propose
items one to six include seven yeah
thank you chairman
um item five to provide members with
planning application decisions in their
Awards how are we going to do next at
the moment we get a parish listener
weekly list would it come out as an
email or
just a little bit clarification on that
uh yes it was actually something that we
used to do and then following the review
back in 2019 it stopped
and then and then we're going to
reintroduce it so what we will do will
produce a monthly list
um and then that will get sent through
to member services and then emailed out
to members thank you
any other members
okay I'm particularly pleased to see
four as a recommendation there
um because that for me is about
providing customer service
and going through a sort of
pre-application process so very pleased
to see that recommendation there
um but unless there's any other further
comments we've got proposals that I
think recommendations that I think we
can take on block and that lets anyone
disagrees
um councilor Ward you look at your field
so thank you chairman do we need to take
item seven as a separate change and then
everything together
I think we can take them all on block we
can take them all on blocks thank you
very much
um so uh
unless anyone who's against taking one
block
I can't see any dissenting voices so
we'll turn to the recommendations at
item two uh those one to seven which
have been proposed by U Council award
seconded by U councilor sparing
um are we in agreement
great
unanimous thank you very much indeed
right
we will turn to um
item seven
and uh
on that subject I believe we have Tracy
Lilly a director of communities and
health with us this evening and I
believe Tracy you're going to talk us
through the item
not sure just just before we go any
further is any possibility of sorting
out this Perpetual whistle that's going
on behind us
all right every time I hold a mic I want
to burst out into song um but I won't I
won't put you through that this report
is just a business as usual report
really around the voluntary sector
grants that we issue each year it's a
total of 25
000 and 10 goes to those that apply for
Grants and 15 is top sliced to cover
rabs funding for
kind of helping us out throughout the
year the report is self-explanatory we
were able to award grants to 12
organizations and there's some really
good comments in the report but I'm
happy to answer any questions
thank you very much indeed Tracy any uh
questions for members
councilor Belton
not a question so much but just to say
it's really pleasing to see that there's
a vast um
diversity and who's getting the grants
and how it's been awarded and the report
does read really well
um and it's positive and the fact that
rabs report on what they're doing and do
a lot of the leg work for us and to
ensure that we're getting good coverage
across the entire district is really
pleasing so yeah just well done
yeah certainly uh I'd like to Echo and I
think other members would certainly Echo
that I attended the revs AGM recently
along with uh portfolio holder councilor
Williams and it is indeed impressive how
they are outreaching and we're able to
support them in their good work but also
to other all organizations as well and
so members unless there's any other
comments
there are three recommendations set out
at paragraphs 1.1 to 1.3 on 7.1 of the
reports I will read those
recommendations out that the processes
and procedures for allocating the
voluntary sector grants fund be
continued for the financial year 2023
1.2 that it be agreed that this process
remains clear and transparent whilst
allowing outcomes with those identified
in the Rochford District Council RDC
business plan relating to partnership
working and links to the Joint Rochford
and Castle Point Health and wellbeing
strategy
hwbs 2022-25.
2025 that is and 1.3 that it be agreed
that the Rayleigh Rochford and District
Association for voluntary Services ravs
receive top sliced funding from the same
pot based on outcomes aligned with the
Essex County Council performance
framework in the hwbs action plan
taking I assume that members you're
happy to take all those three on block
are you agreeable to those decisions
being recommended
agree great
thank you that is unanimous
moving on to item eight
sorry can't you sit there and
opportunity interest in the great waking
Pavilion
thank you very much indeed councilor FD
for that declaration thank you
um
Council Ward I Turn to You to introduce
this report thank you
thank you very much chairman
um well I'm very very pleased to bring
this particular item forward
there has been quite a lot of
consultation with the local Ward
councilors and they are very very
pleased to see this come forward
this is a great opportunity in Social
working
rather than looking at the financial
outcomes of things I think this is
actually a very very important
piece of work that is coming forward
to enable a lot of social help within
the area and I know that this has been
asked for by the local councilors and
I'm I'm very very pleased that we've
been able to bring as a working partner
ATF forward to take this on I mean as we
can see from the proposed heads of terms
and the various other items that they
will be having a 28 year term lease but
with a peppercorn rent from the first
year to the seventh year now they are
going to invest heavily in bringing this
Pavilion back into use which will be a
huge saving in regards to the council it
will be used it will be in working order
and I believe is going to bring a huge
social benefit to the area so I'm very
very happy to bring this forward and the
decision that I would like to see
recommended at 1.1 that the council
owned asset great wakering Pavilion
known as Sports Pavilion and tennis
courts and that's got to be taken into
consideration as well if I may see say
because on the map it shows them in two
distinct different areas so they will be
having use of both those areas
be at least to ATF South End achieve
Thrive and flourish
for use as a community by Sports and
Leisure Center for a period of 28 years
chairman
thank you councilor Ward are there any
other members before we move to that
recommendation a vote on that
recommendation any other members wish to
comment
nope I can only Echo the points that
you've made Council award I'm absolutely
delighted to see these dilapidated
buildings being brought back into
she producers
and Council Walt you've got a second of
your
Council of sparing seems to be the
flavor of the flavor of the day that's
my left hand man the left hand man
good right okay well you've very kindly
read out the recommendation
um members can I ask for your agreement
to that recommendation please
that's five uh in in favor and Council
after you're abstaining
that's absolutely fine so we note your
abstention on that
lovely
all right moving to item nine which is
the lease of the holbridge Pavilion uh
Council award it's your lucky night
tonight
thank you chairman
um again this is another of our assets
that we are bringing back or hoping to
bring back into use it's it's been put
on offer out there to be taken up we've
we've put it out at a market rent of six
and a half thousand per annum we had
spoken to trudge who operate the
Fairview Pavilion but at this moment in
time it doesn't fit into their program
of use
um I will be having conversations uh
with both uh the ward councilors in
holbridge and the parish council for
them you know to be involved in bringing
this forward to see if they have any
ideas for usage and I'll be very
delighted and welcome their input into
this but as it stands it is as it is
there are decisions being recommended uh
on item one do you want me to read those
out uh or not I do propose those if you
wish me or you wish to read those out
save your breath on this one okay who
let me do this one
right uh 1.1 oh you are going to read
them right I will okay
um that the household opportunity be
publicly marketed for the council owned
asset hold Bridge Pavilion a sports
Pavilion located in pool at pool Lane
whole bridged for commercial use
that Authority be delegated to the
director of assets and investment in
consultation with the portfolio holder
for strategic planning and assets to
review the offers from prospective
tenants resulting from the marketing
exercise via local property agents and
finalize the terms of the lease with a
successful applicant for the whole
Bridge Pavilion and 1.3 that Community
use of the asset be recommended unless
there are Community benefits will which
will convert wider value for money to
residents of this District overall
thank you chairman and I will need a
second to thank you councilor Ward and
councilor FD is seconding you and just
in case the audio recording isn't clear
um I certainly heard at 1.1 that the
household opportunity and of course it
should read that the leasehold
opportunity uh that's for the uh for the
recording
um but uh and I should have said on both
this report and the previous report my
thanks to Phoebe Barnes who's director
of assets and investment for all the
work that you're doing on this because
it's a delight to see these dilapidated
buildings as I said previously being
brought back into Community use and the
social value that hopefully this one in
holbridge but certainly the one in
waikering we'll give back to the the
community
um but before I move to a vote
um any member comments
nope okay in that case
um we'll take the recommendations
together 1.1 1.2 1.3 if everyone is in
agreement so those in agreement
agreement
that is unanimous with those
recommendations
we move then to item 10 which is our
update on the cost of living and I turn
to Tracy Lilly director of communities
and health uh for your update please
thank you
um
I've mentioned earlier on today I I
don't have my sidekick as in Kelly so
I'll try to do justice to the dashboard
unfortunately I can't present it on the
screen but I've printed it out for you
and it's been handed out by my able
assistant Kim Anson I'll just give you
some kind of headlines as we thought
that the calls to the customer service
team are very very minimal from our
perspective but actually looking at the
overall reach in terms of communication
across all platforms it is I think it's
quite high it's significantly higher
it's over 12 000 just dropped down in
March but one of the things that we've
made clear about the dashboard is it's a
kind of moving beast in a sense and we
want to make sure that it helps inform
us moving forward and picks up Trends
and one of the things that we didn't
want to do was put more pressure on our
partners to provide additional
information to us to include in the
dashboard and one of the things you'll
see in the handouts that you've just
been given is some day data that we
received this afternoon from citizens
advice and what I don't want to do is
kind of wash that down and just present
a small amount of that I think it's
really important to members to see the
entirety of those key stats that we've
got but it's safe to say that we're
doing a huge amount of work massive
credit to our partners that are doing it
really but I just wanted to touch on it
kind of crossed over two themes but it
did have a cost of living theme to an
event that we ran on the 29th of March
at the mega Center in Rayleigh and we
were able to reach 250 people with 30
Partners present at that event it was
really heartwarming to be involved in I
have to say and I just wanted to quickly
because I think it's really important
read out a couple of thanks that we got
as a team when I say team it's Kelly
Redstone and our Apprentice Lucy
turkleton so they've done really really
well but this email was from Act of
Essex and said just wanted to send a
message on behalf of our team
congratulating you on delivering a
fantastic event yesterday it was great
to bring everything together and it was
made better and Brilliant by the turnout
of the public well done and then another
one from the lead for partnership
delivery at Essex County Council just
wanted to send a quick email to say what
a fantastic job you did yesterday I felt
it was well organized and the great
range of stores covering all areas I
really appreciated the invite and look
forward to working with you again soon
so it was it was really heartwarming as
I said and we will continue to to do
those kind of events because like I've
said all along it's not necessarily
always about producing literature and
leaflets because it's out there already
but it's about making sure that we're in
our communities talking to our residents
giving them the support that they need
we've got about 18 warm hubs across the
district that are well used there are
two particularly they're used but I
won't name them because it's not a name
and shame game but um yeah it's really
good work and we're just waiting for
actually
confirmation whether we're going to be
included in the LGA conference in the
Innovation Zone around the work that
we're doing on the cost of living so
hopefully fingers crossed we'll get to
Showcase what we're doing
thank you Tracy for that update and also
the handouts that have gone around
members are there any questions
counselor Mrs Belton
thank you
um great report thank you for the
information and the the arguably it's
one of the most vital services that
we're delivering at these times and I
just wanted to ask you mentioned that
you'll be doing looking to do other
events we'll be looking to do that
elsewhere in the district because there
was comments about him being in Braley
and making it easier for those on the
east
yeah absolutely one of the things I'm
quite passionate about is actually
developing and I have to bear in mind
that I do put a lot of pressure on the
team to deliver these things but one of
the other things we wanted to do was a
cost of living Roadshow as well where we
won't just do the bigger events we will
go to existing groups that know what
their communities need and we will
present to them in key areas so for
example there's no point going to an
elderly group and talking about mother
and toddler benefit you know family
benefits so it's just about tailoring
that approach but hopefully we'll do
that with our partners moving forward
councilor FD
thank you Tracy for a really great
report
um we've been at this now for coming up
nearly a year
so what what
we're going to do if what we've learned
from this report and what we've learned
over the last year and how we're going
to be moving forward on this
thank you councilor FD well as you know
we initially did an action plan which is
still there and we still kind of review
it regularly but one of the things that
we wanted to do was develop the
dashboard which will give us the data to
inform how we move forward and we'll be
reviewing the action plan in September
because that will be a full year life of
the action plan and then we'll
reevaluate and program what we do over
the winter months and then the come in
months after that
thank you very much
Council sparing
thank you chairman I attended the event
on the 29th of March
um I didn't quite know what to expect
but can only in those what Tracy said
the support and the enthusiasm from both
the the residents who were there and the
people who were should we say showcasing
their various areas was was quite
quite surprising I didn't know what to
say what to expect but it was a real
real Buzz going about the place thank
you
thank you councilor Sperry
any other members
no okay
um
I just want to sort of record my thanks
to you and your team and also to
councilor Williams whose portfolio This
falls under uh certainly we started
looking at this in May of June May or
June of last year and as was said by
Council sparing in the context of the
mega Center event I don't think I knew
we knew how we were going to be able to
be able to support our residents in the
district
um
what we have been is we have been an
organization which signposts and
facilitates and engages with other
partners because we knew that we
couldn't actually deliver or solve the
problem
um so it has been a perfect example of
us working with other agencies we've
been able to make modest Financial
contribution to those under the council
tax with council tax hardship schemes
but to have been acknowledged at least
by the LGA as one of those councilors
that is up there was on the front foot
of doing it I have to sort of say a big
thanks to you and your team Tracy for
the way that you've actually gone on
board with this and produced reports
regularly to this executive so thank you
and to other officers of course it's
teamwork but thank you very much so if
we turn to the decision and this is any
other comments if we turn into the
decision at 1.1 that the update on the
cost of living response and work of the
cost of living working group be noted is
that noted members
noted thank you
and finally for this evening we turn to
item 11
which again is for you Tracy lily as
director of communities and health and
it is the safeguarding policy and
procedures
um I assume yes it is you that's going
to be introducing once again yes sorry
me again
um I'll keep it brief for this one it
wasn't our policies and procedure
weren't due for we know until 2026 but
it's actually best practice to review if
there's any significant change and we
considered that the change of personnel
quite significant so that's included
within this document also we captured
some legislative change and that's at
11.72 which is appendix 10 so it just
tables what those
um
legislation and the day that that we've
kind of adapted in this policy and it's
also about aligning using the Strategic
partnership that we have aligning the
practices across both organizations and
I think this is a really good example of
that there's still more work to be done
we've undertaken member training and I
just want to give some credit actually
to one of the members that recommended
doing a pocket card we're quite famous
for our pocket cards now we're now going
to develop a pocket card for
safeguarding as well so that members
have got that available to them so yeah
it's a really good piece of work
thank you and at that point I did hear
earlier today that Kim was attending
um and uh I thought to myself oh I don't
remember Kim in Rockford and was
smacking myself for not being known but
I now realize Kim and Welcome to our
meeting that your corporate manager
communities Leisure and health uh in uh
Brentwood Borough Council so a warm
welcome to you to uh to the Rocha
District uh and uh and and there we are
for the work that you've been doing in
in supporting this so good to see you
here this evening
um but uh thank you Tracy for that uh
update on this uh on this report members
any any questions any comments
well it is there before you
um I will propose
um that at the 1.1 the decision being
recommended and that is that the joint
revised safeguarding policy and
procedures
2023-2026 for children young people and
adults with care and support needs be
agreed do I have a uh secondary
counselor Mrs Rowe is seconder members
is that agreed
thank you very much indeed that is
agreed
so
members that takes us to the final item
and just before I close the meeting it
is of course the final executive in this
Municipal year
um I would like to just pay tribute to
officers that have supported us through
this year to my executive team that have
supported both the actions that we've
taken through the year and supporting me
so thank you very much indeed everyone
and
there we are I closed the meeting at by
that clock at five past eight thank you
very much